have you ever been a child and found
something scary I have an example I was
living in Indiana seven years old and
everyone was jumping into this Lake and
I sat there all day and all afternoon
while everyone jumped off this big tall
Rock I walked to the edge of it five or
six times and I thought you know what
that's scary I'm not going to do it and
by the end of the day I jumped and
thought oh well that was no big deal I
did it again again then it was time to
go home I was no longer afraid of that
I've jumped off the Rock I'm not scared
of jail anymore you want to send me back
good because if you send me back you're
now going to have to explain to the
world why you're gonna have to show the
evidence this time
so you better prove it
you know whether I get sent back or not
they're going to have to finally show
their cards they've been sitting here
with a seven and a two well I'm a
Crossing with Aces and there are aces
all across the floor and they've been
chip leader pushing their chips around
making their power moves the time is
coming where they're going to have to
put their cards on the table